ROMAN NURIK: We're hoping
there's audio this time.
Anyway, hello, once again.
Welcome to Android
Design in Action.
Your host, Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: Hey guys,
my name's Adam Koch.
NICK BUTCHER: And hi,
my name's Nick Butcher.
ROMAN NURIK: So
today's episode is
going to be about
presenting images.
We're going to share a
bunch of tips and tricks
on how to present kind of
images in a delightful way
inside your apps.
A lot of the things that
we'll talk about today
have been covered
in past episodes.
But we felt that it was good
to have kind of a recap episode
as well as talk about
some minor new things.
Not necessarily new
in Android, but kind
of new things you
should be thinking about
related to showing photos and
thumbnails inside your apps.
So without further ado,
should we get started?
And Nick, do you want to
introduce the Design Principle?
NICK BUTCHER: Absolutely.
The images are such
an important part
of your user interface that
they're specifically called out
in Android's Design
Principles which
say that pictures are
faster than words.
And that you should use them
to get people's attention
and be more efficient.
So there's a much quicker way
to express your information
in your user interface
by using imagery.
If you have screen
full of images
versus a screen full of text
and labels and so forth,
one is going to be
instantly a lot quicker
to kind of understand,
to kind of grok
what's going on, than the other.
So you should really make
use of them while you can.
And the other thing I think is
very important about this kind
of principle is that a lot
of these kind of devices
out there these days,
phones and tablets
and so forth, really kind
of beautiful high resolution
screens.
So it's a real
missed opportunity
not to provide really
useful, crisp imagery
wherever you can to enrich
your user interfaces.
So shall we push on?
So one of the most
important things
when thinking about using
imagery in your application
is very minor.
Designing for Android
is designing for scale,
designing for a variety
of devices out there.
So what that means
is, when you're
thinking about your
images and you're
thinking about how they're
going to display in your user
interface.
You need to build in a level
of flexibility in there
so that your user
interface can work
on a variety of different
screen sizes and shapes
and that your imagery can stand
up to that and still look good.
So this is a technique that
we've covered a couple of times
on the show, so I'll go
quite quickly over it.
But one technique
that works very well
is to respect the aspect
ratio of the image you want
to show but to be
a little bit more
flexible about the exact
balance in which you show.
And one way you can do this is
using a center crop technique.
So what this will
do is, depending
on how much space you have
available to show the image,
it'll kind of blow it
up or crop off the sides
and so forth in order to
maintain the aspect ratio
but to fit in the amount of
space available to the image.
It's a very important
technique to kind of embrace.
And I think as we've said
before, this technique works
really, really well if
you have images which
don't have a
particular focal point.
So for example if you have this
picture of some bacon, which
we always seem to come
back to here on ADiA,
then it works particularly
well for this kind of content.
If you have people's faces you
might risk kind of cropping off
something you might consider
the focal point of the picture,
so just bear that in mind.
ROMAN NURIK: Cool.
Should we move on?
NICK BUTCHER: Next
step we're going
to talk about have
different ways
that you can kind of
decorate or change
the imagery which
you're looking at.
And the first thing we're
going to [INAUDIBLE]
here is using different masks.
So Android has a kind
of particular look
and feel when it
comes to shapes.
So for example, you don't
see many kind of pill shapes
or rounded rectangle shapes.
But what you will see is lots
of simple geometric shapes,
like squares, circles and
so forth. [INAUDIBLE] maybe?
I don't know.
One technique you can
use with your images
in order to break out of a
rhythm and make them pop,
in order to kind of set
them out of new content
somehow is using different
kind of decorations,
like a circular mask
in this instance,
in order to kind of
make it stand out.
ROMAN NURIK: The nice
thing about circular masks
for avatar photos, too,
is that it's a bit softer.
I guess in general circles
are a bit softer than squares
or other things like that.
And it's kind of nice to unify
or to tie this visual element,
the circle, to the
idea of a person.
So not necessarily
circles, it could
be other things, but
kind of making sure
that throughout your
app any time you
show a type, a single
type of object,
that there's visual consistency.
And using a circle
mask is one of the ways
in which you can achieve that.
NICK BUTCHER: And
moving on, here
is an example from
the Path application
which combines that
idea of using a circle
mask with providing kind of a
slight white border and a drop
shadow onto it.
Just in order to set it
apart from the content,
give it a little bit
of content protection
if you're not sure what
the color of an image
is going to be-- it's user
provided-- you can stop that
from contrasting with
the background elements,
for example.
And make it stand out
as well, giving it
a little bit of visual effect.
ROMAN NURIK: Should we
move on to text overlays?
So any time you show
images-- and actually this
is the something we'll
talk about in a bit
with full bleed imagery--
but basically anytime
you show images and you
want to show captions
next to those images, there's
a couple ways to do that.
So first of all, obviously
you could have the photo
and you can show captions below
it, if you have the space.
But one of the ways in which
you can kind of maximize
the use of space, also I guess
maximize the effectiveness
of the photo or of the image,
is to make the image take up
as much space as possible and
overlay any sort of metadata
or titles or captions or things
like that on top of the image.
So here's just a couple of
examples of that in action, I
guess.
So this is from the ADiA app,
the Android Design In Action
app from Andreas.
And you could see that
the images take up
as much space is possible.
There aren't big white
gaps in between them
and then having text
inside those gaps.
This is purely kind of
letting the image take
as much as possible and using
the space on top the image
as a space for the metadata.
So here's another example.
This is the circa app.
The circa app is a recently
published news app.
And here they also have the news
article, or the news thumbnail,
take up almost half the
entire screen, maybe even
a little more.
And then the title is
just kind of an overlay.
And here are just a couple of
other examples from Google Play
Music and the People app.
The reason we wanted
to point these out
is that these are a
couple different examples,
but they each use a different
form of background protection.
And background protection
is basically the idea
that if you just overlay text of
whichever color, black, white,
whatever-- if you just
overlay text over an image,
very frequently
the image itself is
going to contrast too
highly with the text.
And the text won't be
very readable, won't
be very legible.
So background
protection is something
that you place in the
background or some effect
that you provide that
makes the text legible.
So here's an example
in the ADiA app,
there's a kind of
a dark black drop
or rather a black gradient.
And that's a very,
very common form.
Here in the top right
there is the people app,
and instead of a
gradient they just use
kind of a semi-transparent
black rectangle.
That's another common
way of doing things.
And then here in the
Google Play Music app
the action bar is
also using a gradient
for background protection.
So whatever the background
is, whatever this photo is,
even if it's just
pure white you'll
still be able to read the title
here and see the controls.
So the one thing I
did want to talk about
is the way circa does it is
actually very interesting.
It does a combination
of a slight drop
shadow on the text,
which alone is usually
enough to make it legible.
But it also applies
this blurring effect.
And the actual
execution here, I think,
could be a little better.
There could be kind of a faded
blur or something like that.
There's kind of a sharp
edge between the blurred
and not blurred image.
But the idea is that they're
blurring the background
to provide as much
contrast on the text.
So any time you see
edges, for example,
in this photo of a
turtle-- that hard edge
between the turtle
and the hand--
that's actually
visual distraction.
In this case, when you're
just focusing on the image,
that's a good thing.
You want to focus on the
different details in the image.
But here, where
you just want kind
of a more vague
sense of the image,
but you really want
to focus on the text,
they kind of blur
out the background,
make those edges
much, much blurrier.
And make the text
much easier to read.
So a couple of different
ways to overlay text
or overly metadata
on top of your photos
to maximize the amount of
space dedicated to images.
NICK BUTCHER:
Another great aspect
of using these kind
of overlay labels
is that it lets you kind of
say that this whole item is
the interface.
It's kind of the idea of
putting your content first,
and that anything is kind of
within it, contained within it.
So it's like saying
on the People app,
on the example where you have
them calling the contact,
this is the thing
that you can click on.
This is the person.
This is the kind of data
item I can interact with.
And there isn't another
label off slightly somewhere
to the side, so you have
to kind of expand out
of the area to
click on [INAUDIBLE]
or whatever it might be.
It's completely contained.
So this overlay
layer will help you
to build this kind of
data-centric kind of UI.
ROMAN NURIK: It's really--
the image is the touch target,
right?
It's almost like if you look
at modern UIs versus past UIs,
really the content
is the Chrome.
The content is the
interactive target.
And you have here-- when
you let the image be
the target I think you end
up with a much more rich UI.
OK.
Should we move on?
Let's move on to full bleeds.
So this falls-- this is kind
of related to text overlays.
Kind of in a similar manner, we
have some similar screen shots.
But here the idea is
that you want to-- sorry,
we keep hearing IM noises.
Anyway, here the
idea is that you
want the image to take as much
physical space as possible.
You want it to take as much
real estate as possible.
You want your UI, basically,
to be as immersive as possible.
So here's an example
of that where
basically rather than
having the image start
at the bottom of the action
bar, and maybe kind of pushing
the rest of this content
down in Google Play Music,
they actually decided that,
hey, why can't the image be
part of the action bar?
So here they used kind of
a translucent action bar
with again that
backup protection
and let the image go
as high up as possible.
And so here is
basically the concept
of maximum space for content,
maximum space for images.
When you have multiple images,
like in the case of thumbnails,
what that means is
you want to minimize
the gaps between images.
You want to minimize
the space between them.
And so here's again an
example of the People app,
where the space
between each image
is only about one or two dips.
And the idea here is that if
you had larger space, if you
had larger gaps, whether
they be white or black--
it would be extra
visual distraction.
It would potentially help
further the visual hierarchy,
but the hierarchy here is
well established already.
And so extra space there would
be just kind of static space
that's not being used.
That's not really assisting
in presenting this content.
So I think that the fact
there are small gaps here,
I think it services this
content really well.
And then two quick
other examples.
Here's another example
of a flip board.
Again, with very minimal
space between photos,
between thumbnails.
And then here's another example
of going completely full bleed,
where basically the
entire screen is a photo.
And it's not a static photo.
This is kind of an important
distinction to make.
It's not just a
static photo that
is the same for every
time you launch the app.
It is a piece of content and
it's still very, very dynamic.
So the idea is here is that
they spent as much space
as possible showing the content
and then overlaid things
on top of it in a background
protected kind of way-- the app
branding as well as some
of the kind of things
that you could look at once
you've opened the magazine.
So that's full bleed imagery.
Should we move on
to touch feedback?
ADAM KOCH: Yes,
so, touch feedback.
If you've been watching
our other episodes
we tend to mention
this quite frequently.
And one of the reasons
for that is we actually
see many apps that
don't actually
implement touch feedback.
One of the areas where
people often forget
is image touch targets
or touch targets
that are made up
largely of images.
And so one of the problems
with touch feedback
where the touch target is
largely made up of an image
is that you can't really
engage the touch feedback
on the background like
you normally could, with
say text or something like that.
So for touchable areas that
are largely made up an image,
you should really use a sort
of semi-transparent overlay
that covers the
full touchable area.
In terms of the color
that you should use,
it should really match well
with whatever your highlight
color is or your accent color
is for your application.
And the focused
and checked state
should really be about
50% of the pressed state
in terms of capacity.
Actually, let's just
jump across here
and quickly look
at some examples.
So the two on the left
are sort of no-nos.
You can see the very
left example here.
It's highlighting the
background and I actually
increased the
borders a little bit
here so you could even see it.
So to the points that
Roman was talking
about just before, the full
bleed imagery and the text
overlays, often you won't
even have any background
to highlight in these cases.
So that's just not really going
to work where the image makes
up the majority of
the touch target.
The second no-no example here
is not having any transparency.
So not only does this
not look that great,
but you can actually
see some of the content
that you're touching behind.
And here's an example of
just sort of a good way
to do touch feedback
on a particular image.
Another couple of examples, the
press state and check state--
and actually this is a
little tricky to see here,
simply because the
opacity is 50%.
Let's see if we
can zoom in a bit.
You can see it's slightly
darker here than it is here.
But it's a little tricky to see.
So here's a few good
examples of touch feedback
where the image is the
majority of the touch target.
So on the left here we
have Google Play-- oops.
On the left here we
have Google Play Music.
And you can see here they're
highlighting the entire card.
And they're also using
the accent color,
the sort of orange
accent color that's
sort of matches with
Google Play Music.
The second example
here is in Google Play,
the app store itself.
And this is one of the
collections, the beautiful apps
collection.
So you can see here the
cards are actually larger.
And again, the entire card
is being highlighted here
to indicate the
touchable region.
And you can see here the
text is not overlaid.
The description
of the application
actually falls below
the main image.
But the entire touch target
is being highlighted.
And then the last example
here is the Google I/O 2013
application.
And you can see
the avatars that we
were talking about before
with the rounded circle.
And in this case, just
the circle of the image
is being highlighted.
NICK BUTCHER: And as
you were saying before,
I think this is an
excellent opportunity
to really embed your
branding in there.
So I think Google Play Music
is doing a great job there
with extending its orange
branding into the touch states.
Holo design language is in no
way descriptive about color.
And you should really see this
as an opportunity break away
from that default
Holo blue and really
kind of bring your own
branding to the table.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, definitely.
All right, should
we move on to focus?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, absolutely.
So while images are beautiful
and great for grabbing
attention, sometimes that's
not exactly what you want.
And you want to be able to
emphasize other information
or kind of mute that
information somehow.
Some good examples of doing
that, that we've picked out
to showcases today-- the first
one is from the Currents app,
a Google app for kind
of reading newsfeeds.
So on the left you
can see there's
a newsfeed with kind of
nice big beautiful pictures,
and kind of a title and
strapline and so on.
But once you've
actually read that story
and you kind of come
back up to the list view,
they do something
quite interesting.
They actually completely
grayscale the image
and they mute the text as well.
So it fades away
visually, because I've
kind of processed that.
I don't need to go back to that.
And it makes it really
easy to kind of pick up
where you left off or
see what you've read
and what you haven't read.
So this is a great example
of having both visual images
and then subduing them
when you want them to not
grab the attention so much.
And just a second
example, example
just to show you
its versatility,
is actually when I was taking a
screenshot of the Currents app,
I noticed that the
screen shot notification
in the notification bar
does the same thing.
And so the notification
bar-- you're
going to be rubbing
shoulders with all kinds
of different content,
most of it going
to be presented by the system.
It's going to have a
uniform look and feel.
So if you were to use kind
of a full bleed, very kind
of colorful image there, it
might look really out of place.
And it might be kind of
a jarring experience.
It might not look
like a notification.
So they do a nice job of
desaturating the image there,
so it fits in better
with its surroundings
and you can focus
on what's important,
which is the touched target and
the secondary action to check.
ROMAN NURIK: Should we
move on to the next one?
NICK BUTCHER: A slight
variation on this
is combining that desaturation
with the touch feedback
that Adam was talking about.
Sometimes if you
just apply a kind
of semi-transparent highlight
over the top of an image,
you can get unexpected results
with colors bleeding through
and so forth, especially if
it's user generated content
and you don't know
what it's going to be.
To provide more
control to this, you
can actually combine
these techniques
and on touch,
desaturate out the image
and then overlay
your touch feedback
to give a slightly more
controlled appearance.
So in this example,
I didn't include--
the natural state is
kind of a maps image
that had grays, blues, yellows.
But we kind of
muted those colors
and just add the touch target to
have a slightly more controlled
effect.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah,
I think Google Play
Music is another example.
Orange doesn't really overlay
well with some other colors.
So desaturating and then
applying the orange, almost
like applying-- I think it's
a hue layer in Photoshop,
just kind of manually
changing the hue
of every color in the image.
That can kind of make it a
more even look to the photo.
NICK BUTCHER: And
the next example
of providing focus
in the application
is using blur effects.
So similar to the Circa
example you saw earlier,
I think that this is a
Yahoo! weather application.
Which is kind of trying
to run in to mostly
in the same screen.
So on the first thing, it wants
to give as much prominence
to this beautiful imagery, which
its sources can flicker out,
showing just how
rainy London is.
But then when you want
to show more information
on the screen, when you
scroll up to show the forecast
and so forth, you want
to mute that information.
So they do a great job of
applying the blur effect there
to kind of really re-emphasize
the content's changed.
So the content is now prominent
rather than the imagery.
So this is a great technique.
ROMAN NURIK: Should we move on?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
the last kind of focus
that we want to
talk about is just
really applying
a dimming effect.
So you can use this to
the great effect just
to kind of show an
imagery, and then
as you scroll some
text over the top,
in this example from
Grand St., it then just
applies this kind of
fade mask on top of it
in order to give some background
protection to the text
and bring the text to the
forefront for your attention
as well.
This can be really simply
achieved by developers
just by setting the hint
flag on an image as well.
[INAUDIBLE]
ADAM KOCH: Let's talk a
little bit about placeholders.
So I think most apps actually
do get this right, for the most
part, but any image that
loads in your UI that
has any sort of load time,
any load time at all,
should really have some
sort of placeholder there.
I was playing with an
app the other day that
had no placeholders,
and I was just blindly
scrolling through a list not
knowing what was happening.
So it really gives a good
visual indication to the user
that something is
going to load there
once it gets around to loading.
Ideally you should try
and tailor the placeholder
to the final image, if you can.
If you have any sort of
additional information
about the image, maybe the
dimensions, the colors,
things like that.
ROMAN NURIK: Even like a low
res cached version of the image.
ADAM KOCH: Low res
cached version--
and I'll show you a
couple of examples
on the next slides about that.
And then finally when
the image actually
finishes loading a sort
of subtle animation
to transition to the final
image is definitely recommended.
Normally that just means
a fade in or a cross fade.
You could do something
a little more fancy,
but I would just urge
you not to go too fancy.
Really, it should
be quite subtle.
And then on the
development side,
you should just make sure
that image or that animation
doesn't run every time the
list view scrolls up and down.
Getting kicked out, Nick?
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM KOCH: The way
that the list view
works, it does recycle views.
So you've got to make sure that
the animation isn't running
constantly every
time that the list
view is scrolling up and down.
So let's have a look at
some examples quickly.
So this is the Google
Play app again.
And you can see
here-- it's actually
hard to get these screenshots,
because it does load
pretty quickly.
I had to go in
the airplane mode.
Because of the sort of
card-based UI of Google Play,
you don't even need sort of an
additional placeholder image
here.
The card already
conveys that something's
going to load in that space.
So it's a pretty
nice example of sort
of baking it into
the existing UI.
This is the system
gallery application.
It's kind of hard
to notice here,
but actually they
use the dimensions
of the image that will
load to sort of show that.
I guess Nick's having
some room issues.
ROMAN NURIK: OK, so
Nick will join us again.
ADAM KOCH: He'll
rejoin us shortly.
What was I saying?
Yes, so-- as I said, it's
kind of hard to see here,
but the dimensions of
the placeholder image
actually match the dimensions
of the final image.
So if you have a long panorama
or something it'll be thinner.
And if you have a sort
of portrait photo,
it'll be taller.
ROMAN NURIK: It's almost
kind of like you're
at an airport, when the
airplane is landing.
It's almost like the landing
strip for the airplane.
It's kind of guiding it.
It's not really guiding the
airplane-- well, in that case
it's guiding the airplane.
But here it's guiding the user.
It's saying, the thing that
will load will be here.
It's almost like the
helipad, I guess.
ADAM KOCH: And obviously it's
not always possible to do this.
But where you can, where you
have the extra information,
it's definitely a
nice enhancement.
ROMAN NURIK: Seems like
Nick has joined again.
Is that right?
ADAM KOCH: I don't know.
ROMAN NURIK: There he is.
ADAM KOCH: And then
this placeholder
example we really like.
It's the Pinterest application.
And I'm actually not sure
exactly what they're doing.
It looks like some sort
of, I guess, average
of the colors in the final
image that will load,
something along
those lines anyway.
Not only do they show
the sort of dimensions
of the image in the
placeholder, but they also
approximate the color
of the image that's
going to eventually load.
So, again, it was kind of hard
to get these screen shots.
And you'll see the scroll is a
little offset from each other.
But you can see here that
the images sort of roughly
match up across these
two screenshots.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, it's great.
This is one extra
database field, right?
Just one extra
database field that's
computed on the server side.
It just says, take the
image, maybe average
the pixels in some way,
and store that hex color
in this database row.
And with that you get
this massive improvement
in the experience.
And Nick is gone again.
ADAM KOCH: We'll
just keep moving on
and hopefully Nick
can join us again.
The next topic is
fullscreen galleries.
The biggest advice here
is you should really
be using lights-out mode.
And then hiding the
system UI, any sort of app
UI you may have, and the action
bar, all at the same time.
Generally that's engaged
in one of two ways.
Normally tapping
anywhere on the screen
will sort of engage
lights-out mode.
And then tapping back will
bring back all the Chrome.
And then normally there's
a timeout of some sort
as well, like maybe three,
four, five seconds of inactivity
of the user not
touching anything
and the Chrome will
also just fade out.
Lights-out mode will be engaged.
The other thing you should
always make sure to do
is support the
standard gestures,
so pinch open and close
to zoom in and out.
Keep doing moves, Nick.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I think
because we're running late.
ROMAN NURIK: This is what
happens when we do shows live.
ADAM KOCH: And then
double touching
to zoom in and zoom out again.
And you should always
use the standards sort
of paging physics as well as the
standard overscroll glow that
appears when you reach
the edge of the gallery.
And then I guess on
the development side
that normally means just
using the standard ViewPager
class from the Support Library.
For photos, there's a
class called PhotoView
by Chris Banes, who's on
our team based in London,
that you can also use
on the development side.
The last point is really--
in this particular case,
touch feedback is
not really required.
Simply because the entire screen
is really the touch target.
It doesn't really make sense
to highlight the entire screen.
And also the UI really
will respond instantly
to the user's touch, anyway,
because the lights-out mode
will be engaged and
disengaged immediately.
Any other comments, guys?
ROMAN NURIK: No, looks good.
NICK BUTCHER: One of
my bugbears on this
is people who don't implement
the pinch physics right.
So things like, when you have
two fingers down doing a pinch,
you should still be
able to pan around.
So I would just say, use one
of these standard libraries
like PhotoView, because
they do it all right.
They tend to have the right UX.
ROMAN NURIK: Actually,
I'll talk at the very end
when we talk about graphs, I'll
share a piece of sample code
that actually helps
to do that as well.
ADAM KOCH: Quick,
very quick ample
of lights-out mode being used.
Actually, bit of inception here.
We can show the gallery engaging
and disengaging lights-out mode
here, right now, with the
slides that we're using.
And on the development
side, there's
actually a template that you can
use called FullScreenActivity
that is part of Android Studio,
and is it still part of--
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah,
it's part of Eclipse.
ADAM KOCH: --Still
part of Eclipse.
You can actually go
and create all the code
that will get the
exact right behavior
for engaging the
full screen view.
The last thing I wanted
to quickly mention
is transition animations.
So this is an
example from tumblr,
and if you're viewing
posts in screen on the left
and then you tap one
on of the images,
that image will actually
zoom out to be full screen.
And then when you tap, it
actually zooms back again.
And this is quite nice.
So you're not breaking
the user's flow.
On the development
side, is there
is a class you can use
called ActivityOptions.
This is mostly useful though,
when moving between activities,
rather than staying
within the same activity.
But it can sort
of help assist you
build that animation
between, say,
a grid of photos
transitioning to a full screen
view of gallery photos.
ROMAN NURIK: And if you want to
do this not between activities
but between different views
for the developers out there,
there's actually
a training class,
developer.android.com/training.
One of the training
classes on animation
specifically shows you how
to do these kind of zoom ups
and zoom outs animations.
All right.
So I think we were
super long on time.
So I'm going to
quickly just jump
into a bonus topic,
which is graphs.
So graphs aren't really images.
They 're really more
interactive images, if you will.
But we wanted to
just show a couple
of quick examples of
graphs done right.
First I want to mention
that in general, these
are going to be
interactive graphs.
So it's almost like
an interactive image.
I think any time you look at
interactivity, or zooming,
or anything like
that, the Gallery
app-- the System
Gallery app is generally
a very good example of that.
So you see multiple
fingers going on.
Double touch works, and so on.
So I just want to show
a couple quick examples
of graphs in use.
So the first is this
interactive chart demo.
And this is available in the
Android training classes.
So here you'll
notice that you can
do the same thing you can
with a full screen photo view.
You could zoom.
You can double touch to zoom in.
And then the other
nice thing is that you
get edge effects, right?
So if you're looking
to do something
like a graph, or basically an
interactive, information-based
image of some kind, this is
kind of a good starting point.
Another quick example
is the Quotes app.
And we've covered
this one before.
It's by the developer
Michael Pardo.
I think the publisher name
is slightly different.
But if you look at
one of the graphs,
they actually do things
a little differently.
They have this zoom bar,
whatever you want to call it,
I guess.
And they have these
little handles.
And you'll notice that
these handles are actually
using the same visuals as text
selection handles on Android,
so it's very, very
clear what they do.
I think they're
actually inverted.
They should probably be
facing the opposite direction.
But it is still kind of cool
that you can kind of do this.
And then as you touch
and scroll across,
you see the specific
values of those points.
So those are just
two quick examples.
If you want to take a look at
the sample code for developers
for how to do an interactive
chart thing, here's the code.
There it is.
All right, so with
that we quickly
want to do a shout out to
Mike Denny who has just
joined the Android Developer
Relations team as an Android
design advocate.
ADAM KOCH: Woo hoo.
ROMAN NURIK: He's going to be
be based out of Mountain View.
Welcome, Mike.
He'll probably be joining
us on future episodes
of Android Design in Action.
And yeah, I think this
is probably a link to his
announcement post on Google+.
Please, all welcome Mike.
All right, I think
that's it for our episode
after a rough start.
As always, I am your
host, Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: See you
guys, Adam Koch.
NICK BUTCHER: Bye
from Nick Butcher.
ROMAN NURIK: Bye
from Nick Butcher
across three different
conference rooms, right?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, you've had
a little tour of the Google
London offices today.
Thanks for staying with me.
ADAM KOCH: See you guys.
NICK BUTCHER: See you
guys when next time.